detroit seems like
it's always been like historically like
super divided depending on what side
you're from like what side of town
you're from
yeah um there seems to be like
less of that recently like people
working together [ __ ] like that like is
that
is that you know obviously you and peasy
got a whole album together like
um how's the detroit scene right now you
feel like as far as just like
the camaraderie and you know it feels
like there's more
people moving together as opposed to i
feel like it's good like we're in a good
space it ain't you know it ain't really
much beef going on like everybody really
just
putting that [ __ ] to the side and
getting money with this music [ __ ] cause
that's where the bag it and then that
big sean cipher was
[ __ ] crazy yeah because i i don't
think uh i
i don't i because i talked to sata baby
and he had like no idea that like tt
grizzly was going to be on there and
like
oh yeah you know like like he put just
everyone i don't think everyone knew did
you know that like i had an idea
everybody you know who's gonna be on
there but i get along with everybody i
ain't
i don't care yeah you know i wasn't like
i don't put me on a song with him like
how how big of a deal is that like to
have like sean do that you know man sean
been showing us love from day one
of course like when he didn't even have
to he'd been shouting us out on songs
and reaching out doing songs with us so
i got i got a lot of respect for big
sean
like he been embracing this day one
remember you said it's about time though
sean's been popping for a long time yeah
yeah show long ass time for sure man
it's crazy because like i feel like
his album with uh detroit too was like
uh
it's his best part his best body of work
so far sean
cole he's been cold like that though he
used to record at the studio he used to
record
it before he i think before he signed
with kanye oh wow
yeah like he been taking that rap [ __ ]
seriously yeah it's crazy to think his
first album came out 10 years ago he's
celebrating the 10 year anniversary and
i just was like
[ __ ] i'm old man old as hell i remember
when that [ __ ] first came
out old is it like him and mike posner
running around doing mixtapes and [ __ ]